>>What makes it School of the Future?
We always say it was
founded as a school
of technology twenty years ago,
but that's not really
what makes us distinctive.
What makes the School of the Future
is that we really put our energy
and our thoughts and planning into
what are the critical thinking skills
that our students need to be
successful in this global economy
and that's a dynamic process,
so our dedication here is
about making our kids
critical thinkers,
making our kids develop
their analysis skills,
making them be more self reliant
and better community members.
>>I think that what you assess
ends up being what you teach
and especially in like a political
landscape such as ours right now,
that's really valuing assessment, our
school has really had to figure out,
how do we contextualize
this push for assessment
in our school that's
always had particular values
of what it means to be a good school?
We think about authentic
assessment, we're trying to figure
out what our kids should
be able to do,
and what kind of thinking they
should be able to demonstrate.
We want them to say,
when they're in a class,
it's not just like
you're learning science.
You're learning how to
think like a scientist.
Or you're not learning
history, you're learning how
to think like a historian.
So it's really also learning
like the discipline of thinking.
>>There's a huge difference between
thinking math and doing math.
A difficulty that I deal with,
a lot of kids still think
that getting the right
answer is enough.
Like once you have the right answer,
you've done all that could be asked
of you in a math classroom.
The difference is, I want kids
to think that there's more
to a math class than just answers.
Today, they were applying the slope
formula to a set of stairs and seeing
if they were in compliance with
New York City building codes.
Okay, this is the math.
This is how the math connects to
the real life, and that was my goal.
>>The thing the kids struggle
with is when they don't feel
like they're making
progress at school.
And so the more that we can assess
them to make them see their progress
that they're making in a
way that empowers them,
the better that they do academically,
and the more invested they are.
So that's what I go for, is
that constant idea of investment
through the assessment process.
>>The relationship
between the students
and the teachers is very
unique, in that it's like a team,
where you both are
striving to learn the truth
about whatever subject
you're learning about,
and instead of other schools,
where sometimes it's like,
the teacher's just telling
the student what to do
and the student is just obeying, it's
a very collaborative environment.
>>I would say most certainly,
the teachers are more invested
in the thing that they
do because it's theirs.
You know, they have a lot of
pride in their craftsmanship,
a lot of pride in their craft, that
>>they definitely bring to the table,
and I feel like it definitely allows
them to express themselves better,
making them stronger teachers.
>>We're really looking at assessments
to say, we don't wanna be deluded by,
"Well, it looks great in the
classes and the kids look
like they're getting along
and they're raising their hand
and they look like they
have a pen in their hand
and they're saying things."
And so we use assessments to
really hold our feet to the fire
to make sure that our kids
are really making the progress
that they need to make.
>>You can really teach effectively,
'cause you're really thinking
like, "Who is in front of me?
What do you need?"
which I think is the way that
kids feel valued, 'cause they know
that they're working on something
that they need to work on,
and they appreciate you for it.